There's no doubt in my mind that you are going to kill it, and that's what I want to talk about today. PP.
I really wanna talk about this.
Patience and passion. Let's start with passion. There is way too many people in this room right now that are doing stuff
they hate. Please stop doing that.
There is no reason
in 2015 to do shit you hate! None.
Promise me you won't.
Because you can lose just as much money being happy as hell.
Clap that off because it's a real shit.
How do you get money to do what you love? You don't.
Right? I lost a shitload of money when I started doing what I loved. What you do is you position yourself to succeed.
So for example, if you're doing something else and you
And you want to do this thing you love - you do it after hours.
You work nine to six, you get home, you kiss the dog, and you go to town.
Right? I mean, you start building your equity and your brand and whatever you're trying to accomplish - after hours.
Everybody has time. Stop watching fucking 'House of Cards'.
That was a good overheard, right? That was a good overheard.
So, you know what I mean?
I mean, if you want this, if you want bling-bling, if you wanna buy the Jets, if you wanna do shit - work.
That's how you get it!
That all I got. There's just nothing else to say.